es ist eine wissenschaft für sich
youtube was sind die geheimnisse hinter
dem portal werden wir auf youtube
fremdgesteuert oder haben wir alles im
griff
jetzt in klicks und science fiction mit
einem einfachen aber wirkungsvollen tipp
wie youtube wieder so nutzen können wie
ihr es wollt erstmal zu beginn ja wir
werden durch youtube fremdgesteuert
zweitens wir haben durch die
ausgeklügelten funktionen alles im griff
das eine schließt das andere nämlich
nicht aus generell gilt durch die
google-suche algorithmen werden wir
manipuliert und werden nämlich immer die
suchergebnisse gezeigt bei den google
davon ausgeht dass sie uns am meisten
interessieren das heißt google
entscheidet was wir finden und was nicht
auch auf youtube wie funktioniert aber
der google-suche algorithmus und was
macht ihn so einzigartig
mit der öffnung des internets 1993
wurden in den folgejahren zahlreiche
suchmaschinen gegründet wie alta vista
yahoo oder hotspot mit dabei war auch 19
690 beck wird der vorgänger von google
angefangen hat alles mit diesem computer
und einem legendären suchalgorithmus das
ist eine formel mit der bestimmt wird wo
ein suchergebnis in den suchergebnissen
positioniert ist dabei ging der google
algorithmus vollkommen neue wege
die google gründer sergey brin und larry
page hatten eine formel entwickelt die
deutlich relevantere ergebnisse brachte
also bessere ergebnisse als alle anderen
suchmaschinen
sie bewerteten nämlich wie oft auf
webseiten verlinkt wurde also umso öfter
sie verlinkt wurden also umso mehr
andere webseiten sie verlinkt ab
umso besser tauchten sie in den
suchergebnissen auf das war eine
revolution mit diesem trick wurden die
suchergebnisse dramatisch verbessert und
sehr schnell wurde google zur absoluten
nummer 1 suchmaschine im world wide web
in deutschland ist sie aktuell mit knapp
90 prozent marktanteil die absolute
nummer eins auch auf youtube haben die
entwickler eine menge energie in den
suchalgorithmus gesteckt lange jahre
basierte er darauf wie viel interaktion
auf einem video stattfand das heißt wie
viele kommentare unter das video
geschrieben wurden wie vieh likes und
die slicks ist gab und so weiter für die
views des einzelnen videos war dass eine
korrekte bewertung aller links verließen
zahlreiche zuschauer nachdem sie ein
video gesehen hatten
das portal also youtube womit die views
auf youtube insgesamt nicht so stark
wuchsen die entwickler zerbrachen sich
die köpfe wie sie das ändern könnten und
kamen auf eine geniale idee watch teil
wie lange sieht ein zuschauer ein video
die idee
umso länger ein video gesehen wird umso
länger bleibt der nutzer auf youtube und
umso öfter guckt der videos nach einer
sechsmonatigen testphase wurde der
algorithmus im oktober 2012 eingeführt
es war eine revolution seitdem hat sich
die verweildauer der nutzer auf youtube
deutlich erhöht und jeder nutzer guckt
auch mehr videos zudem sind die videos
die empfohlen werden
der qualitativ besser weil sie länger
geguckt werden also umso länger sie
gesehen werden umso besser sind sie
allerdings werden auch bestimmte inhalte
in den suchergebnissen deutlich
schlechter positioniert eine online
talkshow clixoom hat eine geringe
bordstein eine niedrige sehr sauer das
heißt klicks um ist immer mehr aus den
suchergebnissen heraus gefallen und das
bedeutet auch auf der eigenen startseite
werden die eigenen abos nicht mehr
angezeigt wie bitte obwohl ich
angemeldet bin und ein kanal abonniert
habe bekomme ich seinen neuesten videos
nicht mehr angezeigt korrekt der feed
auf der eigenen startseite ist kann
vielmehr auch hier greift jetzt der
youtube algorithmus ein und zeigt den
nutzern das was der algorithmus gut
findet das heißt bei pixum hat ein
großteil der abonnenten nicht mehr
die klicks um videos angezeigt bekommen
was tun
ich als macher habt die inhalte des
kanals ein wenig geändert womit die
watched einen dramatisch nach oben
gingen statt bei mageren 20 prozent
liegt die westantarktis zum science
fiction jetzt bei holla die waldfee
kommen im schnitt 60 bis 70 prozent
aber was könnt ihr was können die
zuschauer tun
dafür biete youtube eine menge tools und
durch die jüngsten änderungen sind sie
noch einfacher zu nutzen
als erstes meldet ihr euch mal an das
ist sowieso das a und o dann wählt ihr
auf eurer startseite stadt empfohlene
videos meine abos noch besser ist
allerdings darunter der tap alle
aktivitäten hier kriegt ja auch die
wirklich relevanten trends mit denn eure
kanäle kriegen virale videos und neue
interessante kanäle viel schneller mit
als youtube legt also für meine abos
alle aktivitäten am besten ein
lesezeichen in eurem browser an damit
ihr direkt darauf zugreifen können
außerdem empfehle ich bei kanälen bei
denen ihr wirklich nichts verpassen
wollt unter einstellungen die option abo
neuigkeiten an mich senden zu aktivieren
damit hat der youtube wieder im griff
und können wirklich das sehen was ihr
wollt wenn ihr mehr über youtube wissen
wollt und vielleicht sogar selbst videos
machen wollt empfehle ich euch das
youtube buch das ich mit einer kollegin
zusammen geschrieben habe linkous in der
bio beschreibung und hier unten in der
anmerkung was meint ihr werden wir durch
suchmaschinen manipuliert oder geben sie
uns wirklich gute empfehlungen wie sind
eure erfahrungen diskutiert es in den
kommentaren
wenn ihr mehr sehen wollt von pixum
science fiction empfehle ich das video
über ein liebes und sex chemie oder auch
das nächste video über den dramatischen
klimawandel also einen noch stärkeren
klimawandel der vor der tür steht
ich freue mich über eure daumen nach
oben für das video und sage wie immer
zum schluss bis dann bleib dran und
abonnieren cosmo nämlich vergessen